[Music]
[Applause]
peacock has asked us to do a holiday
themed episode this week but we were a
little confused because it's too early
for Halloween stuff and it's too late
for Labor Day stuff so we're kind of in
between holidays right now but I guess
the execs already have an idea in mind
because today we got this big box
delivered with a note from peacock
saying it contained everything we need
to put on a fun informative holiday
themed show so what do you say we open
this thing and get the party started
all right
let's see what's inside the Box
[Music]
it's a time for the Amber Ruffin Show
Columbus Day special
oh hell no
we're not celebrating Columbus according
to my contract I have to uh are you
ready to get us started folks I'm really
sorry no I did not expect this I mean
Christopher Columbus sucked but nobody
wants to celebrate that man and it's
honestly weird that some people still do
hey
up Columbus this isn't about you
yes it is you know what I'm fine
it's about you yo lost ass mass murder
and ass piece of [ __ ]
yo pointy hat wearing father little
slave trade ass piece of [ __ ] it's
enough to nice yo discovering a
continent millions of people already
live on ass piece of [ __ ] how dare you
you old venereal disease spreading ass
piece of [ __ ]
hey Columbus
did we lie
no yeah that's what I thought okay we
have to move on but we are contractually
obligated to check in with this [ __ ]
throughout the show so just stand over
there and try not to commit any
genocides
you guys if it's been a crazy week in
America let's find out what happened
today was Russian President Vladimir
Putin's birthday he's celebrated by
annexing some cake
no please
blow out the candles
that is my wish
the Supreme Court started its new term
this week and will reportedly consider
issues like voting rights and
affirmative action and whether Brett
Kavanaugh should wear this to work
I love beer a woman I love beer a little
bit [ __ ] was crying talk about I love
beer don't you question my love for beer
I'm a beer
sexual assault
foreign
Politico election officials are
concerned that groups will try to plant
their supporters as poll workers to
undermine election results this November
but something tells me they'll be easy
to spot
there
I got one despite running on a pro-life
platform it was reported this week that
Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker paid for a girlfriend's abortion
in 2009. the woman claims that Walker
gave her a check to pay for the
procedure and he sent her a get well
card now wait a minute oh no it's
Herschel Walker again everybody
hey
it's Hershel Walker again everybody I
just said that Herschel we are not doing
this I have to get through the monologue
no what we're not doing is letting you
spread lies this is all just speculation
and Tropicana
you mean propaganda
you say tomato I say Sopranos
look I'm here to set the album straight
I did not pay for that woman's abortion
Herschel she has a check from you and a
get well card with your signature
objection your honor I'm not a judge
I'll be the judge of that
now look at here I send money to people
all the time but just this morning I
wired money to a prince and his royal
family in the country of inward
do you mean Nigeria
those are your words not mine
aren't you afraid that this is going to
tank your campaign first of all I
believe in the Second Amendment so I'm
not afraid of Tanks
and fifth of all
the Republican party will be uh
definitely rally behind me are you sure
of course they will or my name is in
Hershey Watson your name is not Hershey
Watson
you say tomato I say Alyssa Milano
Herschel Walker everybody
nerve
moving on
the horror film smile earned 22 million
dollars in theaters last weekend it's
the scariest smile since this one
oh
got myself another judge in the court
[Applause]
my face got bigger
I'm actually a turtle
shop Katz's Deli will release a new Sub
in honor of the New York subway in
pastrami provolone and a little bit of
piss
[Laughter]
Ed that's it
see
thank you
[Music]
horribly behaved yeah if my parents were
physically here oh they asked women
um
please cut that out so I don't get a
weapon where I go
and what are you talking about this on
television and how I gave you a woman
come over here and get this one defend
yourself after the whooping
the UK this month will see the launch of
a bubble gum flavored vodka that changes
from Blue to purple after a mixer is
added and then it changes to a third
color when you barf it up
[Applause]
the barf and piss barf and pissed
that's another woman
and finally in the new animated special
trick or treat Scooby-Doo the character
Velma will be depicted as a lesbian also
all right
me too also in every scene Shaggy is
straight up holding a bong
and that was
monologue did you guys like
it I like it okay now
we have a lot of things to talk about
this week but before we get to all of
that I have a very special surprise
guest here today and I am so excited to
chat with him please welcome actor and
TV icon Kadeem Hardison
[Applause]
you guys
thank you so much for being here oh
thank you for having me
I'm gonna be honest I'm a huge fan a
different world was one of my all-time
favorite shows there's two okay that
goes for everybody and your portrayal of
character Dwayne Wayne was
groundbreaking for introducing America
to a young HBCU student who was smart
and cool
what was it like to portray such an
iconic character oh well thank you Amber
um it was an honor you know one of my
favorite things when strangers
approached me out in the wild to tell me
that they've been inspired by my work I
love that that's what it's all about
that was nothing better okay can I say
something
who said that it was me sorry to
interrupt but I'm a huge fan and I just
had to take the opportunity to tell
Kadeem how much he inspired me oh thank
you uh your work on a different world
showed me it was actually cool to be
smart because of you I stayed in school
worked hard and became a cardiovascular
surgeon
foreign
thank you Kadeem you inspired me wow
your story of sticking it out and
pushing
suing your goals until you achieve them
that's the real headline here young lady
the honor is all mine
oh my God
ah thank you Mr Hardison and Amber you
inspired me too oh
oh yes your work in that sketch goldfish
who smells her own farts underwater it
showed me that sometimes it's okay to be
disgusted plus it was the first time I
had ever seen a black woman fart on TV
thank you you inspired me
great that's great thank you for
speaking up I'm glad I could help all
right now we're moving on uh I also have
something I'd like to say that's not
really how this works
as a young man I had a love for algebra
but was embarrassed because I didn't
want the other kids at school to call me
a nerd that is until Dwayne Wayne came
along and showed me how someone can be
good at math and still pull fly Honeys
now I'm a nuclear physicist with a
beautiful wife and a family of my own
all thanks to you you inspired me
[Music]
a nuclear physicist wow I'm an actor you
know uh the dramatic arts of my craft
but no matter the yarn I spend it could
never shed light on the enigmatic
subatomic life of a quark
thank you for your work you're the real
inspiration here my man
and Amber you inspired me too I did yeah
all my life I've been afraid to sing in
public but then I heard you sing a song
on this show that was so
off-key and
so offbeaten just so bad
I couldn't believe peacock didn't force
the editors to dub it over in post
it was like you were trying to miss
every note get to the point
you inspired me to never be afraid to
let the world hear my voice so hey hey
[Music]
okay you're welcome sir moving on
I just want wait um I also have
something I'd like to say why is every
member miked
Kadeem your work on a different world
was Fearless the show never stood away
from heavy subject matter like racism
the AIDS epidemic or domestic violence
in fact watching you tackle those tough
issues inspired me to achieve my own
dream of becoming an investigative
journalist for the New York Times
[Music]
ah from the bottom of my heart thank you
oh thank you oh uh amber your head is so
very big sit down
dang it will you people just let me
interview this man I love him I brought
him here so I could get to know him and
make him be my little friend now shut up
I'm sorry about that Kadeem now I have a
question for you oh okay what do you do
that brings you Joy
actually
watching the Amber Ruffin show brings me
joy yes yes absolutely in these dark
times your blend of lighthearted humor
and hard-hitting historical analysis
has been exactly the thing we need to
get us through this pandemic
your comedy is an inspiration and it
begs everyone in America to tell the
truth
oh my God thank you kitty that is so
nice thank you oh thank you because you
inspired me to tell the truth and the
truth is you got a big old head
like it's like a boulder how you walk
with his head
you give up because then everybody
[Applause]
yeah my bad Okay so
hey Christopher Columbus what did you
think of that segment
honestly uh I couldn't really follow it
well wouldn't be the first time you got
lost you dumbass
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]